una vez más las disjordania ocupadas se
enfrenta a un recrudecimiento de las
tensiones entre palestinos y el ejército
israelí que este jueves acabó con la
vida de nueve personas en una redada en
el campamento de refugiados de jenning
la autoridad Palestina denunció una
masacre y anunció el fin de la
cooperación con Israel en materia de
seguridad y dijo que recurriría a
instancias internacionales
iremos al consejo de seguridad para
implementar la resolución de protección
internacional para el pueblo palestino
bajo el capítulo séptimo y detener las
medidas unilaterales
acudiremos urgentemente a la Corte Penal
Internacional para agregar el expediente
de la masacre cometida por las fuerzas
de ocupación en yin hoy a los archivos
presentados previamente al tribunal
según el ministro de defensa yoaf Galant
la redada fue una operación dirigida
contra miembros de la organización yihad
agradecimiento y reconocimiento por el
valor de los combatientes de las fuerzas
armadas israelíes que operaron En yeing
esta noche contra terroristas que
planeaban un ataque en Israel desde que
comenzó a contabilizar las víctimas
palestinas en Israel y en los
territorios palestinos en 2005 la ONU
nunca había registrado un número tan
elevado de muertos en una sola operación
israelí en cisjordania Israel que ocupa
sus Jordania desde 1967 lleva a cabo
operaciones casi diarias en todo este
territorio especialmente en las zonas de
jenning inaplus bastiones de la
resistencia Palestina el año pasado
insis Jordania murieron 194 palestinos
una cifra sin precedentes desde la
segunda intifada